إذا سألت قائد الأسطول السابع للولايات المتحدة
كارل توماس ،
فهذا ما يبدو عليه الردع ويبدو
أن الردع قد نجح حتى الآن
وآمل أن يستمر في
العمل ولكن وظيفتي هي أن أكون مستعدًا في
حال لم يحدث ذلك
في الماضي.  أشهر مجموعة حاملات البحرية الأمريكية
الضاربة 3 بقيادة الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
أبراهام لينكولن والمسلحة
بجناح مقاتلة الأكثر تقدمًا في البحرية الأمريكية
أجرت تدريبات مشتركة مع حلفاء
مثل اليابان وقامت بدوريات في مياه
المحيط الهادي الهندية
حيث تعمل هنا بشكل واضح للغاية  قوة ديناميكية رشيقة للغاية
، لا توجد طريقة أفضل لتوفير
الردع الذي نحتاجه في هذا الجزء من
المنطقة ، حيث تجلب حاملة الطائرات هذه
قوة نيران هائلة إلى المنطقة ،
والغرض منها هو إبراز القوة المتزايدة
للأمن والعمل كرادع
لدول مثل الصين وكوريا الشمالية
وروسيا
ولكن  في جزء من العالم يبدو أنه
غير مستقر أكثر يومًا بعد يوم ، فإن
فعالية حركة الضربة الحاملة
مثل هذا كرادع للخصوم
قد أطلق عليها اسم int  سؤال
[موسيقى]
نحن بحاجة إلى
تحالف أقوى لدول ذات تفكير متشابه
لأن صعود الصين هو الآن ظاهرة
عالمية حقيقة لا تضيع في الدول الأعضاء الرباعية
، تحالف مكون من الولايات المتحدة
واليابان وأستراليا والهند
وقادتهما  من المقرر أن يجتمع في طوكيو في وقت مبكر من
الأسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]
مع كوريا الجنوبية يشاهدون من على
الهامش
الدول الأعضاء ومن المرجح أن تناقش
الرد الموحد على غزو روسيا
لأوكرانيا
الموجة الأخيرة من اختبارات الأسلحة التي
أجرتها كوريا
الشمالية وبالطبع الصين
واحدة من  الأشياء التي لا تمتلكها الصين
هي أصدقاء وحلفاء
لديهم موضوعات
لدينا أصدقاء وحلفاء يريدون
الوقوف جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الولايات المتحدة
بشكل جيد ، فالرباعية ليست التزامًا دفاعيًا متبادلًا شبيهًا بحلف شمال الأطلسي ،
وتستمر في ترقية
التعاون الأمني ​​بين الرباعية  تعتبر
الدول الأعضاء والدول الأخرى ذات التفكير المماثل في
هذه المنطقة في غاية الأهمية
للحفاظ على الأمن البحري ،
ولكن وفقًا لما قاله
كليو باسكال ،  متخصص استراتيجي ، إن
مفتاح مكافحة صعود الصين ليس
بالضرورة من خلال القوة العسكرية
بحلول الوقت الذي تصل فيه إلى الجزء العسكري ،
تكون قد فات الأوان تقريبًا ، ولا ترغب في
قطع الصين عسكريًا ، فأنت تريد
منع نفوذها سياسيًا واقتصاديًا
أولاً
ومع ذلك ، بينما تعمل الصين وروسيا على
تعزيز تحالفهما العسكري
في المنطقة ،
يقول الأدميرال جي تي أندرسون ، إن وجود الولايات المتحدة
إلى جانب قوة
حلفائها أثبت أنه رادع فعال ،
ومع ذلك إذا فشل هذا الرادع ، فإن
مهمتنا هي القتال والفوز.
نتيجة لا يريدها أحد سوى
الجيش الأمريكي وحلفائه يجب أن يستعدوا
لسؤال بليك على متن السفينة الأمريكية
أبراهام لينكولن في البحر الفلبيني.